why does anybody do this to themselves I
don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Anita she's a
global pop music icon one of the most
decorated and influential artists on the
planet but first and foremost she's a
girl from Rio and she's returning to a
Brazilian Funk roots with brand new
music inspired by the favelas where she
grew up the latest single is Funk Rave
and the rest of the new music is coming
soon Anita welcome to the show thank you
Howard maybe not I know we can revisit
that question here at the end but before
we get started how are you around spicy
food I I don't think it's gonna be I
mean a nightmare I told my family uh oh
guys so back in Brazil they're on Brazil
I sent a link of the show and I said I'm
[__] in a show and they're like no
you're not you're never gonna be able to
do that because they know me and I say
yeah I'm doing I said why I said my PR
said it's amazing so I'm gonna update my
PR to eat with that well you know what
today Anita we're gonna prove them all
wrong are you ready to get started no oh
well let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm feeling like I'm pretending I'm on a
date the first date oh okay that doesn't
matter what happens you just pretend
it's all good because you want to do
good for the partner that's what I'm
pretending now and I'm here for support
too all right it goes both ways so this
first one is the classic chili Maple and
then you'll start at the handle over
here okay it's this one yep not that one
no no don't okay
I'm crying for the first one
it's already bad
[Music]
it's [__] burning I say bad words be
yourself
so I understand that by Lee funk music
was illegal up until like 2009. what was
it like to be like a literal Outlaw
performer you know doing these shows
this art form that at the time was
criminalized yeah guys so what happens
is like in Brazil the Rhythm so
miami-based Africa bambata these rhythms
in Brazil they were all in English or
other languages whatever and in Brazil
they wanted to understand what was going
on so they would do their own version in
Portuguese and they would add the beats
in in like to sound more Brazilian swag
so it was like
um The Girls Just Want to Have Fun in
Brazil it was
like the Brazilian version of it with a
funk beat in the back more like Miami
Bass Vibe but they would change a little
bit the artists they would sing about
what happened to NFL and then the
government would get pissed and blame it
on the Rhythm while in reality you
should change the reality of the people
there give us opportunity give give us
structure so we would sing about other
stuff you know
[Music]
I told my dad I was coming he sent me a
bunch of amoroids um medicines because
he's had a good dad I'm gonna get
amorites tomorrow
okay so this next one's the curry Verde
here
[Music]
so I'm intrigued by an experiment that
you did on a trip to Mexico where you
asked the taxi cab driver to take me to
a nightclub where the rich people hang
out and then later that night take me to
a club where the poor people go I'm
curious what did you learn or observe
during that experience and then
follow-up question which nightclub
played the better music ah the poor
people
I mean I come from before origin so for
me it's always more fun the Urban Nights
100 like
so I just went to Mexico and everything
went wrong on this business trip and I
was like you know [__] everybody I'm
just gonna really I'm gonna realize
what's going on alone and then it was
super boring the fancy one people were
just saying like this
and I was like Jesus Christ we can't do
[__] so then I left I said okay now take
me to the
poorest one and then it was just
reggaeton and people were dancing having
fun hot guys hot girls it's like this is
my place so I started to Shazam all the
songs and then I went to the hotel I
searched about all the singers and
everything there was J Balvin everybody
I started to text everybody on Instagram
it was great and then I started
everything because I loved it
foreign
pepper I never put lemon on my food
first time Mom Mom I'm gonna put
Brazilian subtitles on this
[Music]
okay this is the easy this is easy
the easiest one from them why did we
start with this first one kind of caught
you a little bit welcome
oh good okay guys I'm so relaxed now
yeah there was no need to be nervous
this entire it was this date I went once
tell me when the guy said oh I'm taking
you to my restaurant right I was like oh
okay and he ordered for me it was so bad
I was hating everything there was so
much I don't eat black pepper right and
everything had so much black pepper and
I don't eat it because I know it causes
amorites me and my dad will go crazy
and then I was just eating and I said um
simple
I was like oh you don't like the Frozen
I love this restaurant is amazing it was
his restaurant imagine if I would say
like oh it's right
terrible terrible food here this this
chicken is better we'll take that we'll
take that all day long all day long
okay good let's go
[Music]
oh God are we eating again that's how
the show works for better or worse
now this one's a step up
so I'm curious how you absorb this one
yeah so good
oh
I feel like the guy at the black pepper
restaurant right now
ghost pepper
so good guys I love it
[Music]
so I'm a big fan of your song Veneno and
then the uh gorgeous musical video
accompaniment that I think gives a real
like body and shape to the song's more
stimulating qualities and the great
tradition of creating songs to make love
to are there any essential ingredients
like what in your opinion makes for like
a great bedroom Anthem I love songs to
make love
I always do songs to twerk but I love
the songs to make love is so good uh and
the music video have a scene from banana
me with this yeah next you had snakes
all around you I love that lots of
people all around you I think a good
song to have sex needs to have that
movement that you feel like you can go
with it you can yeah right
you know and uh I did this um this
course I took a Course once of a tantric
massage
and I think it needs to match that Vibe
of the tantric massager start like with
the physical touch so it needs to be
sensitive not that strong not that hell
yeah
more like oh sensual Sloan
it was yeah it's good and the chorus was
super weird actually but it works when
you put it in reality
[Music]
now it's Los Calientes Rojo
oh my God
now I actually think this one is maybe a
little bit easier it is yeah actually oh
thank God this this show is good for who
have like problems with faking shits
right yeah
it's like a treatment yeah they leave
here they go poop right over that's
right right it's like a medical office
and I'm here prepared for like 50. yeah
titanium reinforced lots of military
technology you know very important yes
there was this one time I went to this
uh fancy hotel I had a meeting
and I needed to go the food it was some
I needed it I love this about you by the
way
in the beginning of the meeting I was
like oh my God and I left and I went to
the bathroom of this fancy fancy fancy
hotel
I think everybody was knocking at the
door because it was like just one
bathroom
and then I was like oh I'm busy I'm
coming and it wouldn't go down oh no I
was splashing flushing flushing flushing
flesh when I saw the water was coming
like on the floor I was desperated and
it took me like 40 minutes there and
then they put like stripes on the
bathroom it was like shut it down yeah
yeah but they shut it down and then when
I came back to the meeting they were
like where were you I said oh I just
took a little walk
I'll take a phone call real quick it was
bad probably they put this one in the
food there
the spicy shark eat the heat I don't
know if I want to eat the Heat
boy
sorry no Let It Go Let It Go I
understand in these situations
[Music]
[Applause]
I know I know for someone who's never
had hot sauce before that is
break
hi guys I get it I get it
so I noticed that to this day you'll
still direct many of your own music
videos including for your recent hit
involver which at the time of this
interview has something like 600 million
views how do you think about pairing a
song with the visuals like does it start
with the choreography
and then grow from there is it more
natural than that
oh
so
no it depends on the song and then on
the video sometimes when I'm um in the
studio I already envisioned this the
video like the colors are there
yeah I'm like singing cutting the song
I'm in love with movies series
everything so I like to get inspiration
from that so in Funk Rave the scene of
the chicken the chickens running yeah
it's from City of God because that's how
the movie kind of starts there all right
are you ready to move on here to Sauce
number seven hell no you are doing great
by the way not ready my lips are still
burning ringing ringing so this one is
the jalapeno Chico here in the sevens
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how does that work this whole like cat
licking of the milk thing is that
working out
it's a news it's a new tactic I've never
seen it I'm just trying to put my tongue
and leave it here
until it gets numbed
so in a 2018 interview with paper
magazine you said I think when you're a
star you should know that you're there
open to critics and everything are you
the kind of artist who hears and sees
everything like how committed are you to
reading your own press oh I don't give a
[__] I used to
um I used to read every day Google my
name and see what was happening oh this
actually helped it did help
dude not that much but it helped a lot a
little uh I used to read everything I
used I used to be like on top of my [__]
what do people saying do they love me do
they hate me nowadays I don't give a
[__] because people are getting crazier
with the time online it's crazy people
just create
stories everyday worst stories and um
you need to be online 24 7 posting 20
million social medias and then people
say this and say that so I just decided
to let it go I don't give a [__] I just
do whatever I want to do so I just
stopped it
this has a what's the name of this in
English a actual bomb yeah atomic bomb
this doesn't look healthy for good for
your system for your health yeah it
can't be for your body it can't be
sodium
benzoate what the [__] is that it's a
medicine yeah I don't know
you know I shoot first to ask questions
later with this sauce you know like the
less I know the better
[Music]
and this will be immediate
[Applause]
awesome
hey
you saw
[Music]
oh I'm gonna cry
Just Let It Go just Let It Go
have you ever eaten anything like that
in your life
I might join you at that
why does anybody do this to themselves I
don't know
oh
hi
oh my God
you know what yeah yeah tell me talk to
me
this is worse than pepper spray I'm
gonna walk with this some criminal calm
here have a wing yeah somebody
stop them in their tracks
if someone come steal my [__]
if somebody come steal my [__] I will do
this
I was ready I was ready
[Music]
if you had to pick just three Brazilian
snacks to always have on your Rider what
would they be I heard that like pasta
Tempo that's the truth
I would say
biscuit Global it's like um
Global
um cookies it's not cookies it's like um
you guys would call ships we call
cookies in in Rio it's a a type of
cookie that we sell on a beach
and then
we eat we eat a lot of corn
on the beach so we wouldn't put that in
our bags
um
[Music]
Brazilian candy
there's one called
there's one called uh
there's one called seven Bello
seven Bella really good
best soccer
my stock is like peanut butter but a
square of like peanut butter stuff is
really good it sounds delicious right
about now
how are we feeling
terrible I know I get it I get it
but let's go
nobody if you have this you just
throw it in somebody's face I'm gonna
have this if somebody comes fight with
me that means no one's fighting with you
nobody will I have this I'm gonna say
something
I Surrender
[Music]
gonna be the whole night getting [__]
up by this [__] one bite it's enough
watermelon ghost
[Music]
that sucks but nothing like the last one
the last one hurts I know I know
so it almost kind of clears everything
out of the way you know what I mean it
was so bad that you're almost numb I
could eat just about anything right now
that's right that's right
so I've never been more fascinated by a
celebrity product line than I am by
[__] by Anita
gynecologically tested intimate cologne
for your private parts I put it today
because I knew I was gonna sweat so much
and I don't have panties on because of
this dress they put me so I I threw it
today oh
my nose
is it a product that you'd maybe
recommend like let's say for a a man who
has a day job where he eats uh scorching
hot chicken wings every week
yeah I mean for me sometimes the [__]
guys working the whole day he doesn't
realize his balls smell that's right he
doesn't realize the balls are smelling
your balls when you work the whole day
you wanna [__] when you come back to to
from from work home
[__] you your boss smells bad
and you gotta use the [__] thing
because you buy Anita I gave to my
boyfriend he loved it I was like oh yeah
it smells so good and his dick smell
perfect with it
all right Anita
[__] how my lips are so is it red or
like big
better than fillers and Botox
cheers
[Music]
thank you I got some extra
I see the face
I know
but the good news is
I know I know
whoa but you did it
you did it it's all behind you
it's just a memory
ah
come on
Anita to close things up
yeah you know while researching you I
was so taken by your just Relentless
positivity you know I think that that's
really what's kind of taking you from
the favelas of Brazil to around the
world breaking your music incontinent
after continent there's a word when I
started coming here to America and I
didn't understand English that well
when people met me they would say that I
was this thing and I was always smelling
myself to see if I was smelling
something fruity they said it was
refreshing yes I asked my teacher what
is refreshing they do they like my
perfume is that fruity or something but
then I understood what are the positives
that you see in the wings of death like
is there anything nice that you can say
about having your mouth incinerated by
hot sauce
nothing I just think I just think it's
good to see people's reaction to torture
to this type of territory because it's
not like bad tortures like some people
like it and I think
it's good to see I don't know you go you
get to know people better according to
their reactions to this [__]
but pleasing about this nothing but just
the talk well you know what I learned
about you today Anita that you are brave
that you are a warrior because you took
on the wings of death as someone who's
never eaten hot sauce in their lives and
you are still on your feet and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life oh
yeah guys come on
I have this new uh
bundle coming out and um right now this
month some days I forgot the [__]
dates now I'm still tripping on this
what is my two other songs together with
the funk Rave which is kazikaze and I
used to be a hoe and um
great songs with great videos I used to
be a hoe but now I ain't no more that's
what I say in the song
whoa
here you go ice cream coming in
thank you wow how can you do it
you know what the shitty things that I
have to do from time to time not as bad
as like the shitty things that have to
do is like just my life you know so so
true that's the way I think about it
okay so I want this for a friend of mine
you can have it I want this for the same
friend of mine okay
um oh there's one for another friend and
there's one for my protection personal
protection
[__] you your boss smelled bad
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans if you've ever watched hot
ones and wondered to yourself how hot
are those sauces really I could get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
mother
[Music]